[Music]
hi there
Heather again hi I'm Priyanka you've
probably seen me on GCP live YouTube
series I'm also a customer engineer here
at Google as a seee I help companies
understand their big data having access
to big data adds no value unless there's
a way to use it that's right
big data requires a way to perform big
queries which brings us to the topic of
today's episode Google bigquery today's
data is complex and handling it requires
a massive investment in system
architecture and hardware it doesn't end
there though you need strategies for
scalability then it needs to be managed
and maintained the result a system what
quays can still take minutes to hours to
run but what's more important developing
the infrastructure or finding insights
from your data well this is where Google
bigquery comes in it's a fully managed
massive scale low-cost enterprise data
warehouse running on top of Google's
proven compute storage and networking
infrastructure so by replacing the
typical hardware setup for a traditional
data warehouse with the bigquery service
there's no infrastructure to manage no
database and administrator and you can
focus on analyzing data to find
meaningful insights using familiar
sequel bigquery can serve as a
collective home for all analytical data
in your organization bigquery is
fantastic for running ad-hoc queries and
aggregating queries across extremely
large data sets and it's really fast it
can scan terabytes in seconds and
petabytes in minutes this makes
interactive self-service exploration of
massive datasets viable which means
better analysis more creativity and you
can drive more interesting insights from
your data
McQuaid does not replace every
Enterprise data store though for
instance it's not an online transaction
processing system and it's not geared
towards applying changes
they happen since bigquery is a
self-contained cloud-based solution it's
also not an on-premise solution query
and storage resources are allocated
dynamically based on your usage patterns
got a really big query bigquery scales
for you using the processing power of
Google's infrastructure sharing and
collaboration are easy you can control
access to both the project and your data
based on your business needs such as
giving others the ability to view or
query your data and because you can use
standard sequel queries anyone can get
involved replicating data across
multiple geographies ensures a 99.9% SLA
you're always going to be able to access
your data and you won't lose your data
bake query also encrypts all data at
rest and in transit by default in terms
of pricing bigquery separates the
concepts of storage and compute this
allows you to scale and pay for each
independently you can either choose a
pay-as-you-go model or a flat rate
monthly price now the fun part quick
laps you can check out the links to
start the quick labs yourself here these
laps Royd and introductory walkthrough
of how to load and quai data using both
bigquery web UI and the command-line
tool
keep in mind that these labs will take
about 30 minutes each to complete at
this point in the lab we've loaded a
custom data set into the new table we're
going to preview the table and query the
custom data set locate the table in
bigquery open the table and click
preview to view the data click compose
query query the baby names data set in
this demo the query displays the top
five boy names for 2014 well that's all
the time we have for today we hope you
enjoyed this episode on bigquery that's
right don't forget to keep listening our
on-air webinar series quick labs and our
blogs all the links are below you can
learn more about bigquery through our
Google cloud on-demand courses on course
thanks for watching and we'll see you
soon in case you missed it be sure to
check out last week's episode where we
discuss Google cloud storage you get to
walk through a quick collab on creating
and managing storage buckets give it a
shot